we're working on a steak sauce we're
developing a steak sauce for people
uh we're gonna launch that in a few
months we're trying to steal
a steak sauce recipe from a
restaurant there i really wanna i i
the what is the way i've always wanted
to have a sauce
a steak sauce and i want it i
i'm not gonna take it from a place but
i do like i've gone to restaurants where
i go this is a good steak sauce
do you know what i'm saying here like
what's the problem yeah
are you selling your steak sauce no so
then why am i not
you're inspired i'm inspired by it
i'm inspired by it and it's going to be
very good we're developing it we're
working with a chef
we'll try to do up a steak sauce and uh
and and then sell it and bring it bring
it to market
so that we can you know you know we
don't have to
like worry about these other companies
telling us what to do and say
you know freedom of speech that's right
steak sauce freedom of speech i just
like to say things that will make the
people that hate me hate me so much more
and by connecting steak sauce to freedom
of speech which
you know is absurd uh the people that
whose job it is to hate me all day which
is by the way good gig
good gig um well
people just don't like you there are
people that it's like it's like the q a
thing it's the same with comedians it's
like
everybody starts off going like i'm
gonna be a comedian and then that's
queueing up people like we're gonna
save the kids and trump's gonna be the
king and then none of that happens and
then everyone's angry
at me people started out trying to be
comedians can't scratch two nickels
together
can't get a following have no audience
and it's my
fault how is it my fault they've been
doing this
longer than i have but years and years
and somehow it's i've done it to you
what or or other people
other successful podcasters or people
we've all we're the problem
we're the issue and they all cloak
themselves in politics and they're like
i just
i could never i could never
stoop to the level that you've stooped
to the people you've spoken to
okay congratu congratulations
congratulations
i hope has has that gotten you anywhere
has your refusal to talk to anyone
gotten you anywhere still no
still no so you've refused to speak to
anyone and you haven't stooped and still
nothing
i'd start stooping i'd stoop
as low as humanly possible you roach
it's just there's a lot of people
there's business right so i understand
they'll kill nothing i understand when
everything you believe
doesn't work out and it doesn't work out
because you were stupid to have believed
it in the first place
that's why it doesn't work dummies
and then you can't get that angry at
yourself because what happens
you go to the holidays and you go like
this with the gun in your mouth mummy
you can't get that mad at yourself so
you have to dole out your hatred in
little bits
little bits and it's got to be i'm a
problem and it's
rogan or it's this guy or that guy and i
hate him
first of all you broke [ __ ] if anyone
had asked you to sit next to alex jones
not you would have sat next alex jones
in all of you would have in a minute by
the way
why because no one is asking to do
anything with anybody
so stop getting angry at me this isn't
even a specific person it's just
there's people out there it's just i
just don't understand like
how embarrassing is it you're living in
the heyday
of leftist not really leftists but more
liberal non-comedy you're living that
hey that if you couldn't make a buck
sucking now you'll never make a buck
you didn't even have to be funny you
just had to go [ __ ]
show up at stephen colbert's office and
and [ __ ] i don't even know claim to
be an eskimo
on your mother's side and write nine
horrible monologue jokes and you got 3
500 a week
if you didn't make a living sucking
because i know you hate podcasts you
hate all of us because we make a living
like being funny
with our fans it you know it's it's cool
it's
it's fun for the most part it's some of
it's not
um but if you couldn't
if you couldn't get a writing gig and
then all these woke people
you know what they all say to you they
all tweet about how horrible
podcasting is all for it's right-wing
fascist and then you know what happens
when you go hey man you got a writing
job they go no i'm white
i'm a white guy get a good writing job
what you sound like the right wing guy
i'm not complaining about not writing on
you know
boko haram's new show or whoever they're
giving a show to
on [ __ ] cartoon network i don't give
a [ __ ] the funniest new comedian
boko haram like whoever i i mean no one
cares
no one cares or or whatever whatever
terrorist group sounds
eerily like the name of a comedian
you know i'm a fan like you know i'm not
mad that
i didn't get the netflix special they
gave to ansar al-islam
doesn't matter to me
doesn't matter to me i like antarel
islam
some of the bits are good you know
that's good
but it's just so funny all these people
then they turn around and they say well
i'm white i can't get i
i can't get in the writers room and i'm
like okay
i'm like but yet all you do you know
how's the how's the non-stop
capitulating
and and to self-flagellation and
disgracing yourself
and throwing yourself at the altar of
those that would seek to impoverish and
destroy you
how's that working how has it worked
how has it worked doing nothing but
throwing yourself at the altar of the p
the same people that want you to be
homeless
and to be like they're so good they're
so
funny you're so good has everyone seen
this new
show it's so good
grow up you're too old all of you you're
too
old you're old you're elderly your
credits are like
network television show you people are
trotting out like the drew carey
i mean it's sahara what were you people
on empty nest
enough zh1 chat shows i mean
sahara here it's crazy
let it go go to a farm go away
christ almighty with these people you
can't make a dollar in comedy now you
don't even have to be
good if you're a woman
and you don't own four houses as a
comedian right now
kill yourself
you dumb [ __ ] you should
own nine houses
if you're a minority and haven't gotten
a set on conan
hang it up hang it
up okay
and if you're a funny white guy and you
can't scratch together a couple foul on
a patreon to pay the rent
you ain't a funny white guy clean it up
get it out enough with the whining
if you are a funny white guy that's
being ignored by the business
and you can't scratch up a couple of g's
on patreon you can't scratch up a few
friends
then it's time to put the horns on and
go to the capitol
because you're living in a gold rush
of [ __ ] everything they make is [ __ ]
so now you can do something good shane
gillis is doing it
nick mullen's doing it i'm doing it
other people are doing it
do it ryan long makes sketches every
he he's doing it andrew schultz is doing
it there are people doing it
just shut up and do it who cares or
don't
or do it for your people do it for your
fans that whatever they want
you know i remember when i got to l.a
people were like yeah well yeah
you got in with the rogan crew but i'm
not really in with those guys cause i'm
not an ultimate fighter where do you
think i met joe at a fighting gym you
dummies
i'm a fat [ __ ] you just suck you're
not good
who told you you were good
sue them sue them the people that told
you you were good at this
me sue them you should be knocking on
their door going
what the [ __ ] you told me that was good
well you're ki you are good a little i
don't know what happened
they're like yo i'm not into mma so i'm
not here with those guys i've never said
anything
to joe rogan about mma ever
ever we've never had one cover i said
what do you think's gonna happen with
the jake
uh paul fight and i asked him once
if uh one of the hulking lesbians at the
frozen yogurt shop
was amanda nunez he said no that was it
i
i have no interest i don't give a [ __ ]
it's whining all the time everybody
everybody's
so some i'm too good at my job to make
money mullen had that great point
where he's like that people are like too
funny to be funny
they're too good at their job to make
money what
this is if you're like in the industry
it's like this is like the golden era of
sucking at comedy if you can't make
money now god forbid
god forbid it goes back to a point when
like the minimum amount of talent's
required
then you're really [ __ ] all you have
to do right now
is kind of show up look decent and talk
about how much kamala harris
has made you feel energized about the
future of the country
i mean stephen colbert kimmel they're
all crying they're all
crying you'll never leave to spend time
none of those people will ever be
respected ever again
none of them they've all destroyed their
legacies destroyed and they were very
funny
they've destroyed their legacies by
being mouthpieces
of a political and getting out and
crying and being unfunny
and being absurd they're forever not
funny anymore
you will never see them and i don't care
what they do maybe they maybe they
donate a lot of money to breast cancer
good for them
but they will never be funny ever again
ever ever ever again
so that will never be funny again unless
they reverse course
hire nick mullen shane gillis me and
candace owens and unless they do that
and i don't see that happening but if
they don't do that they're [ __ ]
forever
sorry if you don't let candace owens
host
and have me shane and nick then you're
not then it's not going to be funny
and higher the leftist red scare and
the period or whatever these you know my
period and
karl marx or whoever these [ __ ] you
know uh
uh you know uh sardonic [ __ ] are that
are pretty funny actually
bring them in too who cares but if it's
just the same
[ __ ] northeastern liberal arts school
concert or like
being fat is my oh shut up like it's
over it is over this pandemic killed
those shows it's killed us in that it's
killed all that but it's opened the
space up
for other people to do [ __ ] so just stop
[ __ ] whining stop [ __ ] wanting i
have so much more respect for that [ __ ]
that got me to the capitol
then i do these dumb people that just
sit there and [ __ ] whine just do
something
just do something i don't care what it
is it doesn't matter
it doesn't matter what it is to me or
anything i don't care what the [ __ ] you
do that's why i don't rat on people
i don't know what people are going
through i don't rat i don't call people
up and say
hey you should be in trouble storming
the cat i don't know why those month
those [ __ ] stormed the capital
though there were kids inside i mean
i don't know they had to find out there
warrant the old-fashioned way
okay and the black lives matter people
are burning down bodegas and i don't
really love that but i don't you know
i've had some real attitude
from some of the koreans in a bodega
real attitude and i'm not even black
they get a lot worse
so i don't really get involved
you see i don't wrap people out i don't
get involved stop getting involved
cut your friend group in in in don't cut
it in half cut it in nothing
strip it up get them all out of your
life
go down to vegas they're happy to have
you the hoarders are happy to have you
the restaurants are happy to have you
they're happy if you park your car you
can just go to vegas play a few hands
lose then go back up to the hotel room
ordered a chocolate cake we almost
vomited it was horrible
it was like the display cake they gave
us it was very bad but
but it's enough with the who cares
and i again i know that is not
applicable to many people it's just my
own twitter timeline it's my but this is
my own show and i whine about the [ __ ]
that i want about
so it's my own timeline of people that
just it's just exhausting
what and they're getting old these are
people in their 40s and 50s
that are old and they're complaining and
it's like guys
it's not cute anymore it's not
cute no one believes everyone
that's uh leapfrogged you in this is a
nazi
how how [ __ ] lucky for you
huh how coincidental you imagine they're
like telling their
children which they won't have they're
like well i was on a great path in
comedy but then comedy was taken over by
nazis the kid would be like well what do
you mean
actually it seems like mainstream comedy
is just full of people that
believed all the things you believed
well so what did you do
did you spend all day smoking weed and
drinking water
you don't understand i was dealing with
my mental health and
i had anxiety and depression i was manic
depressive i had
you know i had multiple personalities
and none of them were funny
none of them so that's all i'm saying
i'm saying that we're trying we're
developing a steak sauce
it's going to be very good it'll be the
greatest sauce
that has ever touched a steak and we're
we're we're we're
we're uh we're doing all we can here
we're meeting with the chefs and
food developers and i want to get into
the food business i really want to own
i just want to open a restaurant and be
done with this i hope that hurray time
horizon for that is ten years
five to ten years i just want to own a
restaurant
and then blow my brains out on opening
night in front of everyone once it's
once
everybody's there and everything's nice
and everyone goes this is really good i
just get in the middle of the room like
bud dwyer and go
good night just to see like blood all
over ben and his wife's face
as they said they'll have made enough
money that so they won't care and they
they just sit there eating
unaffected yay
having their basic [ __ ] conversations
about nonsense
about god only knows what they talk
about when i'm dead they
can't talk about killing me talk about
the length of grass on someone's lawn
you know you know